so and we try something today which will
probably go wrong but we want to show
you an idea and that's an idea of how to
lead discussions computationally and I
would like to start with a very short
example here of how discussions are
often led today and this is a discussion
this is on the BBC and it's the
discussion in a panel and one of the
speakers is a is a celebrity scientists
in the UK Brian Cox and he discussed
this climate change with someone from
Australia who says there is no man-made
climate change and I'd like you to look
for a moment at this short video and
then we will see what's going on if I
can start it this is now a clear global
problem and the absolute absolute
consensus is that the human action is
leading to an increase in average
temperatures absolute consensus it I
can't I know you may try to argue with
that but you can't the key point is can
we respond is it do we have the
political institutions and the political
will and the organization globally to
respond to this challenge and that
worries me immensely I don't think we do
at the moment and I'm absolutely stunned
that someone who is inspired by Richard
Fineman a fantastic scientist who
believes in empirical evidence is
quoting consensus I brought the graph
first of all that the data has been
corrupted and we know that the 19 as far
as I'm concerned politics should be
based on empirical evidence or policy
should be based on empirical evidence
I've heard consensus which is not
science I've heard appeals to Authority
which is not science I've heard various
solutions he's really great
[Applause]
okay that's that's basically it so my
problem when I saw this is when I see
lots of discussions is that actually on
either of the two sides there was any
evidence there was no data there was no
model there was nothing and then I
thought well if I speak with colleagues
and they are being asked so what do you
think about climate change then they go
oh yeah there's broad consensus so look
at the IPCC kind of thing I knew there's
broad consensus in science that this is
man-made and but it's happening and then
you say how do you know how do you
personally convince me based on data
based on motivation but what do you
personally know about this and then
that's basically it so there's obviously
consensus look at the papers it's there
but there is no argument so the question
that I had was can we do discussions in
a different way wouldn't it be time to
lead discussions in a way with actual
arguments ideally with computation and
how would we do this so if we were to
discuss some things say about climate
change or about any other kind of thing
malaria we discussed and we discussed
traffic accidents road accidents we
discussed droughts we discussed
tornadoes we discussed everything so we
ran this a couple of times how would
this go and I don't think that we found
the perfect solution on the contrary so
we'd actually this is more like a cry
for help do you know of technologies do
you know of things we could add to this
to make this work so one of the things
is we need to be able to program the
entire thing in real time so we want to
be able to do everything live in a
discussion and usually the two of us sit
in quite different corners of the world
so we use different technologies like
zoom for example to discuss this we need
to be able to exchange code Stephenville
from said in the keynote that they are
working on collaborative documents so
that we can work on the same document
that would be a big deal at the moment
we don't have this so we try to use the
chat system
if it works it works very well but it
wasn't necessarily stable enough for
what we were trying to do so so that
this is gone I think I now start this
year so where we are right now is that
we well we discussed that this is wrong
so that this what we see in this debate
is wrong and the question is what can we
do to improve this and what we believe
is that if we put the language into
voice from language that would be a good
start
so can we speak the Wolfram language not
in the sense of reading it out loud but
can we actually work with it so my my
kind of feeling the philosophy behind
this is that at the moment if you look
at the computational converse on a
computational essay it's kind of Latin
it's kind of thing you write down you
translate you work with that's all fine
because it's much much better than PDFs
or static documents but that's not how
we use a language so if you ask a Latin
teacher can you speak to another lesson
teacher they say usually we can't but we
can write it out so the whole trick is
in speaking the language using it and
this is what we've tried beyond just
spoke about our degree in Aberdeen where
basically all the teaching is live
coding
we have problems want to live code and
we want to solve this so in how far can
we get analyzing these topics in real
time so basically putting the language
into Wolfram language speaking it so at
the moment we came up with this here
which is kind of the setup I'm using
right now even though it doesn't work
fully so this is how it works we've got
one computer which would be say my
computer at home we use a little game
capturing box which is a cool thing that
breaks the screen
so there's another rule don't touch it
there you go
yes there we go so it's a red box like
this like like this I don't touch it and
basically it eats the output from my
computer and puts it on a screen like
here right now this would be that screen
and it also moves it forward to a second
computer which basically is recording
everything and streaming it to twitch so
that we can basically why do we do this
because if I do everything on my own
computer on the laptop and do then
complicated calculations it doesn't
stream reliably
so now I have one computer totally for
the streaming OBS Broadcasting System
and we have the other computer that is
free now that computer here is supposed
to run zoom which means where I can have
a couple of people with zoom calling in
and using for example codeshare other
methods to share the code in real time
this computer technically would often
have a larger storage and perhaps GPUs
for for net network training and and so
on
so if we had interactive documents we
could all work on this would look a
little bit different we don't have it so
basically the person sitting on this
computer acts a little bit like a
moderator they can either take the code
via culture and paste it in a notebook
and you basically develop this notebook
as you speak or alternatively they can
hand over control to any one of the
other members which is possible with
zoom or other technologies so basically
this goes then directly to twitch and
soon we've done a couple of these
discussions in the past today and we can
tell you more about yes
yes it's not ideal but it works we tried
other technology for and the problem is
that you see the second machine which
would be this computer in this point is
basically completely independent my
Mathematica runs on this machine they
are not really connected this is just
like a really like eto career so if I
had zoom there and people would chat
with you would share with me send a code
via that system it wouldn't work because
it would be on the wrong computer no no
we got Alan and uncle BT on the other
side so right now we have offsite who
can contribute to this discussion okay
of course we wouldn't necessarily do
this if we were sitting in the same room
but the idea is that we can do these
discussions worldwide so we have to set
up I can explain more about the setup if
you want and then we prepare usually for
these conversations and that means we
have shared folders Dropbox folders and
other things where we have data prepared
and basically what we do is what do we
want to learn about or discussed in the
next session maybe the next week or the
following week so we pick a topic there
is a topic of conversation on the news
or something that it's of interest for
to investigate so in this case okay we
wanted to see the history of malaria and
the cases where you have the cases
before and what's going on now and fine
models now this document is or this
dataset is special because it contains
the raw data it also contains the steps
of the data cleaning and if you look at
the very bottom it would even contain
rudimentary code here that allows me to
represent the data so basically a person
prepares this and says that's a piece of
data I would like to submit to this
discussion thereby I make it available
for everyone to criticize so if you
don't believe my argument that's my data
if you don't like my featuring
there's my data tell me where I'm going
wrong
which makes this much more
evidence-based than exactly people who
might exactly so what you could do you
could now go and say well if I think
this is manipulated give me another
dataset for this conversation put it
online put it in the same format and
we'll have a look at it exactly of
arguments which is what we do in science
but this could be for any any kind of
discussion where you just open your
arguments up instead of saying our NASA
manipulated this or on the other hand
showing a graph and saying well this
comes from the IPCC you have to believe
this because that's technically an
appeal to a higher authority it's not a
he's right it's not a scientific
argument and these discussions seem to
be lacking arguments so by doing it like
this
perhaps we can open our arguments up and
actually have them tested by friends and
checking out what they think about this
and say about this so we try to stick to
this kind of scheme that we clean the
data in that way and say raw data this
is what we got from the internet there's
the URL so you can go to that URL you
can see what people did you can
manipulate the data and you can agree or
disagree with my representation of it
and of course we make use of existing
technology like the from data repository
and other things but it turns out that
very often we bring in data from from
the outside yeah so here are a couple of
before we start we try to do one later
but before we do this we just wanted to
show you a couple of examples of what we
did in previous ones we have recordings
of these the first ones are not
particularly nice I would say we were
testing the environment and trying the
different options from how to connect so
okay so we have different things here we
have for example as to archeology
so this is the data set we have land
viewer which is providing satellite
images actually relatively recent
satellite images so if for example there
is a tack on this story with a
conversation about the attack the
supposed to tag from Iran on the Arab
with an Arab refinery so you know we
were discussing this how do we know what
happens okay why don't we go and look at
geo images and we know that there's a
site called Lam viewer then you can get
up-to-the-minute images so we pinpoint
it to that and obtain the data and then
we started looking at this structure
whether the destruction happened in what
side so form where could the missile
calm that kind of information then marco
stated okay I remember I read up
something on the newspaper today about
the looting of tombs in Egypt why don't
we take a look at the images around the
valley of kings and queens and this is
actually called after archaeology now so
that is satellite data where you fly a
satellite over a certain region like all
along the Nile and you have this data
not only in visible light you also have
heat and so on so radar right you've
lied for some regions as well so you
basically try to look for different
light reflection or absorption and if
there are structures under the sand in
Egypt you see the structures lighting up
if you do image analysis if it's so
you're basically sitting in your office
and you try to figure out where there
are sites in Egypt and count bathing's
or something like this this particular
thing here it's something there's a
there's a scientist pretty popular for
for doing this kind of research and what
we did here this is in Egypt and that's
a site where after or during the
revolution in Egypt looting happened at
these ancient sites so from the
satellite images you can see little
little bits where people who dug stuff
up and you can count and you can see
where that happened and how often that
happens so you can remotely more neat or
even if you can't go into that country
you can remotely monitor what's going on
we try to replicate the results of a
paper so it's why don't we do it with
Mathematica see if what the paper shows
we can replicate I mean it was quite I
mean we then because we divvy eight
quite a bit so you start talking about
something I think you have a plan but
then the discussion it's like a pub
discussion it just goes anywhere yeah so
there were things you could do with
counter it because if you have different
spectral bands you can see where the
trees are healthy so we looking at olive
trees and in Spain or something like
that and you could individually for the
trees find out that tree is sick and
that tree is actually doing pretty
violent things like that so that was one
this year is the vegetation so basically
look for change over the year in
vegetation and these are all things that
happened during the discussion so
usually we try to limit this to an hour
of one and a half hours and end up doing
it five hours yes hours so very often it
is actually long things who wrote
accidents in the UK what we studied when
these road accidents will happen what
time of the day where they happen and
then because you've got all these nice
technology so you can actually go to the
individual roundabout and say why do
accidents happen what do we think at
that particular roundabout you can
actually walk around the roundabout with
Google and you can actually check what's
going on you see another one this is one
we're going to talk a little bit about
today so this is climate change and
that's because I had that introduction
with with this so what can we do
computation so we try to do this
basically for the remainder of the thing
we also had so some reason one of us was
interested in that the crime statistics
in Atlanta yeah we're you shouldn't go
and where you should go can go so it can
be very practical things you want to
know about your city you want to know
about what your government is saying
about climate change whatever okay so
this should be you see yeah that's that
let's try one
why not so if you have this was the zoom
and this is the co-chair thing so the
idea would now be that I open up a
window with Mathematica I'm actually the
setup here is a bit awkward for me
because I can't see what I'm typing so I
have to see what I'm doing there so that
will slow me down a little bit
do you want to know you know yeah so do
you want to participate we've got
another computer oh you're there yes and
there is a zoom no yes I know but I want
this tool because usually I would have
two screens so one is the one that's
being streamed and the second one is the
one that I could because I have to do
coding as well if I do that on the
screen
Green that's being scree streamed I'm in
trouble because the con I can't actually
work like that so it if it works we put
on that second bit on this on this bit
of the screen we will put were from
church for example but at the moment
okay so look at that they hunt mice I
don't care what color look behind the
curtain so this would now be behind the
curtain so that would be what the
moderator fees and in this case oops
that is this disk or chair is somewhere
on co-chair and can show me some code
please anything just a plot of something
okay so that's very simple code so if
anyone is on code share I should be able
to see if you you send me code my code
sharing is what you think
can you see that
so again here's the cool thing so if you
go to the right codeshare you should be
able to should be able to type in I need
to share my okay okay
no you should just if you typed I should
see it so it should be you should see
that on zoom now to refresh it okay
there we go there we go
so I could now take this code so if you
were say this is this is relevant for
climate change I'll just paste it in
there we could run it and we could
discuss this of course we're from Chet
would be ideal for this but okay there
we go so I think that there was some
some data to show to us
you sure people do get in you yeah fives
there dq3 seven okay so do you have that
okay oh there we go okay so there we've
got all of this so
[Music]
can't see after what this to my sight
now we on the moon climate change
do you have anything or can you see can
you not see it you know I don't have the
data I mean I just won't run yep I
already put this data there so what we
we try to do is we try to get data in
here yep
okay then what about my dick whatever is
doing that let's start with something
I've got yeah
so I delete pace let's say once we have
the data and we analyze the data one of
the things you might want to do is you
want to predict on the data so one of
the things you can do is you can look at
a simple motor and this is the model
that we hopefully will be able to
implement why we're talking so there is
a model here that I can open so it opens
a website and this is something you
would for example find during this
computation conversation you would see
ok here is a model where I can say how
much co2 we emit at any point in time
and you can move this forward and based
on this basically kind of try to predict
what's what's happening in the future
and what they do there you see the kind
of based on what how much co2 I am it is
the emission now they co2 level in the
atmosphere would go up and that means
that the temperature goes up and what
they've done here they have actually
made a really really simple model that
is actually called a very very simple
model and if I give you this link here
let's go
okay so then you have the motor and you
actually see the equations as well at
some point yeah and you have also
different IPCC scenarios so what this
model basically does is the following
thing we first want to clean this and
again it would open my model up to
criticism so I clean all this kind of
the data and I put a couple of things
you know I'll tell you what this means
so this model says we have our certain
parameters we have a temperature in 2010
which is fourteen point six degrees so
this is here and this year will be the
co2 level in 2010 we have a couple of
parameters for this model and this is
the emission this is basically just the
emission of carbon dioxide is actually
just a carbon part of the emissions and
we have a value for the degradation of
the carbon dioxide so basically what I
can do now I can I need two equations
for this and these two equations go
right here so I've got the co2 level and
that is the entire equation that this
model does for co2 so it basically says
there's 1 minus degradation so there's a
certain fraction for the degradation and
the next co2 level depends on what I put
in the atmosphere right now so I've got
the emissions here and it turns out that
if I have 2.3 Giga tons of co2 in the
atmosphere that would increase the level
of of molecules by 1 part per million so
1 ppm and this is where this 1 ppm comes
from and again you could now in the
discussion this is what we didn't only
have that last time you could say why I
don't believe that why is 2.3 gigatons
actually one part per million and what
you can do is you can ask well from
language directly say how much
atmosphere do we have natural language
input it gives you the amount of
atmosphere and then you can basically
just take your late
but 12.3 gigatons of co2 do so that's
the first thing so this would allow us
now to make a kind of list of what co2
does and the next equation would be how
does the co2 influence our temperature
and this is a very common law so you
have the s log so it's a logarithmic law
and this is the ratio between the co2
levels right now and in 2010 and with
the parameters I've given you just here
so once this model is there now it's up
for discussion of course this model has
lots and lots of flaws it's very simple
there are all sorts of feedback effects
which are not not considered and people
could just criticize this and if I run
this so simple a date this plot
whatever not done
degradation it is yes exactly it should
be it's just it's a recursive definition
if I have two co2 level last year I can
calculate the two co2 level next year by
knowing how much I am it and by how much
is degenerate or degrade it so this year
in that case would be a very very simple
model or a very simple assumption where
I say I have the same level of co2 being
added to the atmosphere over time so I
can now of course plot other things such
as this is temperature so I can see
under this scenario how would the
temperature behave and again you could
criticize this yes and with a technology
component works we can pass coal along
so what we'll do now is Marco's going to
release the share of the screen and I
can chose some other things on this side
stop sharing if you can give me the
connect cuttlefish there to control my
screen now No
so as Marko was saying
he was going to discussing the emissions
maybe you can move that to the other
screen fantastic what we do is we do
share the data content so for example
this example I'm going to focus on the
ranking of countries based on the
remission and we can see that 30% of the
emissions of C of carbon in the
atmosphere is done by China's second the
United States you see their ranking by
people so you know that to get a double
click this okay is that better
okay better so any effect on the global
amount of emission in the atmosphere
needs to come from the top-level
countries right if 30 percent comes from
China and then 15 percent from United
States then India that's what the focus
should be it's also interesting that you
can look at the emissions by country so
firstly because we have all the data
there we can start taking a look at the
details on the history of each country
per se so by exploring for example the
United States since nineteen nineteen
hundreds to today this is the total
amount of emissions of carbon the this
is liquid so this is gas you can see
interesting things from history the oil
embargos in the 1970 consumption goes
down of gas fuel this is basically cold
that keeps going up up and up until this
time in which fracking starts and in the
united states will replace in the energy
from from coal to gas which lowered this
emission so you see that this emission
is coming down and it's being replaced
by gas another interesting
you know many countries of carbon
burning hydrocarbons those are not in
this data set it's only on that so we do
get burnt it's a big component that one
but you know you have - yes yes and
there is these other ways to measure
that so but this this data said is we
what about the consumption not not on
agriculture but but on consumption it
was an interesting case here that if we
look at China right so we have been
moving manufacturing of goods to China
and look at me since 2000 the growth not
only in their manufacture but also in
their infrastructure building steel and
building cement requires a lot of energy
carbon a calcium carbonate for the line
to build and as you can see most of the
carbon comes from coal so solid
consumption energy is necessary for any
society to to move so if there is a
solution we need to find a solution on
the call the carbon code that it's being
burned so one of the alternative -
although it's discussed by many people
is well you know move to Jen for nuclear
energy and that's what Bill Gates was
trying to do on getting that first
reactor being built in China because it
attacks that main source which is solid
solid radiation then we did all kinds of
other analysis now go so back by the way
if you because if as you say there might
be other sources of co2 for example
oceans also so how much co2 do they
capture and store yes and that you can
then of course compared to historically
records on the model that are just
presented yeah and see that it fits in
certain ranges pretty waves before the
situation right now it actually fits
very well but if you go back in time if
you take paleoclimatic records it
doesn't
so because other effects might be
relevant so you can actually check
whether the model is valid for this or
not so for the example this is taking
the we looked at all the records for
paleoclimate the Bostock ice ice
analysis oh and also getting data from
NASA on the irradiation so the yellow
line is the Sun solar irradiance and
this is basically calculated based on
the Milankovitch cycles you can go
forward and back in time so this is the
amount of energy going in and the blue
line is the delta T temperature and this
is carbon so you can see certain areas
or certain times if you see the
correlation as you say right between co2
and temperature most of the time it does
but there are certain paths that you
know this a complex system it goes
through that it's not necessarily the
force that it's driving the temperature
change so these are the things that you
can observe by looking at the data you
can look at for example we did a study
on the energy of the Hurricanes
accumulated cycle of the Energy Trends
so you can see how many how much energy
was released by the Hurricanes in each
season accumulate that do a linear plot
and showed results so this is by looking
at just the data hopefully by
integrating the signal if there is a
change on angle you will see that it is
more or less and it looks pretty much
aligned so this ask questions okay is
that really is there more accumulated
energy in storms being generated and
this is all the data comes from NASA
tornado analysis we looked at for
example the tornadoes there is a
database with all the tornadoes going
back in time
so usually pathology works this is
basically what's being program
as we speak so these are kind of typical
outcomes of discussions that that you
would have and get out are giving you
control but then if the control comes
back yeah I can do this so what I would
do now I would take these these records
and would say here I've got data about
about co2 levels so I take yellows data
and say these are the co2 level you see
here it's about below 250 and this is
this is from the Year Zero basically to
2,000 you see the change in co2 levels
and based on the model I could now say
okay what does that mean for
temperatures and so on I can go through
the climate models and co2 emission
scenarios that the United Nations have
or I can just visualize this and try my
own scenarios out and what you see is if
I compare my model predictions to the
actual data that Diego had I can see
that this is this is basically the kind
of things I see from about 1900 up to
now this is the blue data is measured
and the orange kind of thing is what the
prediction is and the interesting thing
is that for this it fits more or less it
predicts the trend I can go into the
future so my follow my my equations what
they would say for the future I can look
at the with around here the prediction
error so I can try to figure out what if
parameters are not perfectly known where
would we go but then I can go back and
critique my own model because I don't
trust it and I can basically take
paleoclimatic data so this is co2 levels
in much much longer time scales and what
you see then is that you have these very
very large fluctuations we also have
data about the temperature in these
times so I can basically compare data
and so temperature and co2 levels and
now the cool thing is I could of course
plot this one versus the other to figure
out whether my model works
is if my model predicts the relationship
between co2 and temperature so this is a
double excess flow it's a resource
function where you have the temperature
on the right hand side and the co2
levels on the left hand side of course
you see a clear common pattern here but
the model is only buried for a certain
type of situation so if I run this on
the model you see well I get kind of
this and then there are large excursions
which basically are kind of these guys
here yeah so we did try working on a
collaborative environment we tried a war
from chat in several sessions that
didn't work called culture io we were
only two you work fantastic it seems
that now that we put more people in it
does have some issues but I think the
interesting bit is that for example you
see that that's the that's kind of the
red line is the curve that our model
predicts the connection between between
co2 levels and temperature the the old
records would show you that kind of the
blue kind of stuff that doesn't look at
all like the like the red ones but in
the kind of region where we currently
are so there is a it seems to correspond
so it's made for this particular
situation which again is interesting
because if you say that the models
predict that co2 will go up an awful lot
but the model is not bid for that
particular situation then of course the
predictions get awfully wrong and then
you have to ask yourself about the model
because should work there we know there
are other components that would also
talk about those changes in climate so
which are those components are those
active or not and you could I mean
because you have all this interactivity
in Mathematica we build these kind of
manipulate hope that this runs now I
can't see whether it's doing anything
it's not where you can actually look at
different emission scenarios they
manipulate oh there we go
and you can say I can actually this is
the time when my climate
policy set in so if I change at a
certain threshold and you see the x-axis
there and I say I decrease for example
my output with a certain percentage and
you can say depending on on where I
start decreasing it so I decrease my
output you see that has an effect and if
I decrease it later and later that'll
undo this to a certain kind of ratio so
I can basically study with manipulate
different scenarios for how I change my
transmissions in the future and when I
start doing this and you actually see
that if you go about 30 years in the
future and you reduce it much much more
basically to zero that we still do not
certainly not need these climate kind of
targets so in combination of the data
and the model you can then decide what
what you believe is true about this okay
there we go
and here are so to compare then our kind
of model where we can we can shift kind
of our mission scenarios this works by
the way this is when you when you
program life you see that when you do
the same thing with units it's too slow
for a manipulate so we just do that
without units for this and that's
basically the biggest problem so how do
you get this fast when you run it but
then we also looked at a number of
emission scenarios that they suggest and
you basically plug this into your model
that's there and can can kind of see how
these would basically pan out in the
future based on that model so what we
what we have if you have better ideas
about the sharing the codes because at
the moment the co-chair I usually worked
for us pretty well yes the Wolfram chat
system was a little bit too unstable for
longer conversations even though it's
good because you have got the sliders
and everything in there directly so
that's an advantage
I was really easy to for example would
call chair you cannot send objects like
a data set or at times
there's no translation so between the
war from trap it was really easy I will
to try if you if you just drag it okay
or copy paste we can try to copy and
paste basically also directly to
manipulate you can you can copy in if it
works so if you if you just have an
output in form of manipulate you could
just plug that directly into the chat
and it works and then what we can do
because this didn't work with the
streaming well we can even you could
even do one pictures in that in coach
here it a couple of times and this is
you can share the Karner between your
main notebook and the chat system that
means if you have variables in there
they work directly in the chat system
and you get nice transcript but the
chatting was really nice because we
could actually put that 3/4 and you you
could see it so ok so what are the
takeaways for us on all the conversation
what did you experience so what we can
show you a couple of videos we've got
videos of the ones we did weather with
the most set up environment and we can
we can share these videos so we can we
can put them on and let you see what
would be enough to and I think actually
turns out that the most complicated
thing is not the live programming but
it's basically the technology to
exchange this for the remote
collaboration that's the problem because
that's not fully implemented niveau from
language I guess and I think what we
tried is that usually if you do this
it's about one moderator and two people
or three people discussing is idea
then you have one who can manage the
system and you've got two or more people
actually leading the discussion which
which seems to be a good it would
compromise there you have any questions
[Applause]